if you could return to 1948 and describe
something that you've mentioned the
nakba which means catastrophe in Arabic
what was this event what was this
displacement and dispossession of
Palestinians in 1948
well you know like May 15 1948
um
is commemorated every year as you know
the anniversary of the knuckleberry but
I would even argue and I think this is
like an
a very popular
idea is that the network did not begin
or end in 1948 the 48 was rather you
know a crystallization
of the Zionist Enterprise in Palestine
um and what what happened was that
many zionists
paramilitaries that again today merged
and made the Israeli Army which calls
itself there's really Defense Forces
even though they're literally always
aggressor
um
committed atrocities and massacres and
you know they
destroyed over 500 Villages they killed
over 15 000 people they forced
a very large portion a majority of the
Palestinian population
uh to flee their homes and this was you
know
the near total Destruction of
Palestinian society that continues on to
this day we refer to it as the ongoing
nakba and you see it in in
Hebron and all of these people losing
their homes and
in many cases time and time again you
know I grew up and my grandmother told
me the stories about the knuckleberry
she told me stories about her neighbors
who
were
running away in a panic and they had
mistaken a pillow for their offspring
and they just took it with them and they
realized later that they forgot their
child and they came back for many many
people who were separated from their my
grandmother herself she lost her husband
for a few months for nine months he was
imprisoned by the Israelis
um
you know she told me all of these
stories and she wasn't just reminiscing
about them she was
you know
letting me know that this is still
happening and then and I didn't need to
grow up that old to see it happening in
my own front yard to see that expulsion
happened in the same fashion she's she's
talked about it but
you know now they have replaced their
artillery with the Judiciary
they have replaced you know the the the
slashing of the pregnant women's bellies
in the Daria scene Massacre with with
laws that say you know you're not you're
not legally allowed to be here we're
going to kick you out of your home and
it's happening and it has happened in in
broad daylight
um one piece of context for The Listener
who doesn't who is not familiar with the
neckbe
Isabel for declaration
which was a promise quote unquote
promise made by the British
to the Zionist movement in 1917
uh committing to The Establishment I'm
quoting I think word for word committing
to the establishment of a Jewish state
in Palestine
um as if Palestine was you know the
British to give away
um
and there was this whole movement that
called for colonization of Palestine and
there were different there were
different schools of thought in Zionism
you know people like zanguo said that
this was a country without a people
um and Palestinians who have existed
there who have cultivated the lands who
have you know
had diverse cultural and religious and
political uh practices they were
completely erased and other people like
zobozinski
um
were a lot more explicit and a lot more
honest and said that we need to fight
the Palestinians because they love their
land much like the red Indians love
their lands and he had a paper called
The Iron Wall colonization of Palestine
must go forward
um
and all of these all of these schools of
thoughts were then shopping around for
you know Imperial support
for their cause
they tried they tried to get support
from the Ottoman Empire they tried to
get support from Germany and this is in
the 1800s and then they got support from
the United Kingdom a great book to
recommend is the 100 year the Hundred
Years War on Palestine
um that's the you know traces the
Zionist movement oftentimes in designers
own words
um and so today what we're seeing is a
continuation and you know people like
zabotinski who are like profoundly and
explicitly racist who have called for
genocide who have uh called the
Palestinians barbaric who have
said and done
racist things you know Japanese also was
like the founder of the ergon one of the
other militias that later merged to
become the I the Israeli Army uh which
was responsible for the Darius in
Massacre which was responsible for the
bombing of the King David Hotel
um this is a person who's still
celebrated in Israeli Society there are
still streets named after him and
Netanyahu just two weeks ago if I'm not
mistaken honored him in a public
celebration
um so this is Zionism it's not even
through my own
words what he said to people
that describe Israel as having a
historical right to the land
so if you stretch not across decades but
across centuries into the past
this kind of thing is a red herring um
it's a destruction because you don't
think of any state
as having rights but there is this
exceptionalism to the Israeli regime
where it is it has a right to defend
itself and it has a right to the land
and it has a right to shoot 14 year old
boys because
it thought they had a knife in their
pockets you know a lot of the time
people cite the Torah and site religious
books and you know sometimes zionists
will even say like read the Quran and
blah blah blah you know regardless of
whatever was written in these books that
were written thousands and thousands of
years ago the fact of the matter is no
one has a right to go on slaughtering
people removing them from their homes
and then continuing to live in their
homes continuing to drink coffee on
their balconies
um decades and decades later with no
shame with no introspection
with no reflection that's no one has the
right to do that no one has the right to
keep an entire population of people in
arcades
which is what's happening to people in
the West Bank who have no freedom of of
movement which is what's happening
in Gaza which is blockaded
to water air and land and
is deemed uninhabitable by human rights
organizations like the UN no one has a
right to do that